Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. In the second of our special podcasts, looking back at the sporting event of the season, the Rest Is History Prime Minister's World Cup. Now, in the first podcast, we look back at the first round of games, most of which went entirely as expected. But then, thanks to the indefatigable Jonathan Wilson,
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、无广告内容、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。你好，欢迎收听《历史的余味》。在我们的特别播客系列的第二期中，我们将回顾本季的体育盛事——“历史的余味”首相世界杯。在第一期播客中，我们回顾了第一轮比赛，大部分比赛的结果都在意料之中。但随后，多亏了不知疲倦的乔纳森·威尔逊（Jonathan Wilson），
who did the draw for us and did a bit of mid-tournament punditry, the draw threw up some titanic clashes in the quarterfinals and we had more than a few shocks. Tom Holland. This was the real business end of the tournament, wasn't it? When you get to the quarterfinals, the blood is flowing, the heart is pumping. There's that immense sense of tension in the air.
他为我们进行了抽签，并担任了半程赛事的评论员，抽签结果在四分之一决赛中制造了一些重量级的对决，我们也经历了不少冷门。汤姆·霍兰德（Tom Holland），这是锦标赛真正的关键阶段，对吧？当你进入四分之一决赛时，热血沸腾，心跳加速。空气中弥漫着那种巨大的紧张感。
You must have loved it. I really did. I really did. And, of course, what the fans are all talking about, a clash for the ages, was the match that we knew, if it came about, was going to be. Because we're talking about one of probably the greatest rivalry in prime ministerial sporting history benjamin disraeli against william hewitt gladstone it was the draw that people wanted to happen and it happened amazing just thank you lady luck um yes it was a great match actually wasn't it it was a great match because uh who took the lead gladstone took the lead i think didn't he yeah and then disraeli came back and disraeli went
你一定很喜欢。我确实很喜欢。当然，粉丝们都在谈论的那场世纪对决，是我们早就预料到如果发生一定会很精彩的比赛。因为我们谈论的是首相体育史上最伟大的竞争之一：本杰明·迪斯雷利（Benjamin Disraeli）对阵威廉·尤尔特·格莱斯顿（William Ewart Gladstone）。这是人们期待已久的抽签结果，而且它真的发生了，太神奇了，感谢幸运女神。嗯，是的，那确实是一场精彩的比赛，不是吗？这是一场伟大的比赛，因为……谁先领先的？格莱斯顿先领先的，我想是吧？是的，然后迪斯雷利反击，迪斯雷利
into the lead yeah and held the lead for a hell of a long time gradually over the course of the evening gladstone clawed it back and he ended up winning by 54 percent that sounds quite a decisive margin but it really wasn't it but that was a match that just kind of went backwards and forwards. So what was really fun about that was that was the one match, I mean, of all our Rest Is History World Cup matches, that was the one match that really seemed to catch people's imagination. So you've got people piling in who probably never even listened to the podcast, desperate to vote.
取得了领先，是的，并且保持了很长一段时间。随着傍晚的推移，格莱斯顿逐渐追了回来，最终以54%的得票率获胜。这听起来是一个相当决定性的优势，但实际上并非如此，那场比赛简直是跌宕起伏。所以最有趣的是，在所有“历史的余味”世界杯比赛中，那是唯一一场真正抓住了人们想象力的比赛。所以你会看到那些可能从未听过这个播客的人也涌进来，拼命想要投票。
And I could see people on Twitter saying, come on Disraeli fans. Somebody put that sex worker bothering bastard Gladstone is about to win. And people, you know, passions were genuinely kind of running high. I can't believe that people are voting for Gladstone
我可以看到人们在推特上说，迪斯雷利的支持者们加油。有人说那个骚扰性工作者的混蛋格莱斯顿快要赢了。人们，你知道，情绪确实非常高涨。我不敢相信人们会投票给格莱斯顿
or for Disraeli. I was busy catching up with line of duty ready it's going out on sunday so i'm going to cram in about five episodes and um it's it's very addictive i mean you very hard to tell your eyes away but honestly every 10 minutes i was checking my phone to look at the score with that and updating my family who had no interest in it whatsoever but i was still keeping them informed now tom for uh listeners uh who didn't listen to the last edition of this podcast got no idea what we're talking about completely
或者迪斯雷利。我当时正忙着补看《重任在肩》（Line of Duty），准备周日播出，所以我打算一口气看完五集。嗯，这非常让人上瘾，很难把视线移开。但老实说，每隔10分钟我就会查看手机看看比分，并向我那些完全不感兴趣的家人更新情况，但我还是坚持让他们了解最新进展。现在，汤姆，对于那些没听过上一期播客、完全不知道我们在说什么的听众，
mad i should say that we at your suggestion actually we organized a world cup on twitter where people could vote and we had a series of knockout rounds where people could basically vote for i can't remember we we didn't call it the greatest prime minister we just called it the prime ministerial world cup. So the criteria were deliberately vague. Yeah. Yeah. And people sort of had the day to vote and prime ministers went through in
我应该说，在你的建议下，我们实际上在推特上组织了一场世界杯，人们可以投票。我们进行了一系列淘汰赛，人们基本上可以投票给……我不记得了，我们没叫它“最伟大的首相”，我们只是叫它“首相世界杯”。所以标准是故意模糊的。是的。是的。人们有一天的时间来投票，首相们在
the series of knockout rounds. And the Disraeli Gladstone one was the one that clearly caught the imagination, not because people have a very keen interest in 1870s politics, but because it cuts to the heart of the way that we remember figures in history, because it's all about, it's all about sort of projection, and it's all about the kind of cultural baggage that historical characters have. So if you like your historical characters flamboyant and fun
一系列淘汰赛中晋级。迪斯雷利对阵格莱斯顿的那场比赛显然抓住了人们的想象力，不是因为人们对1870年代的政治有浓厚兴趣，而是因为它触及了我们记忆历史人物方式的核心，因为这完全是关于投射，关于历史人物所承载的文化包袱。所以，如果你喜欢华丽、有趣、
and patriotic and sort of swashbuckling and a little bit dodgy, then Disraeli is your man. Whereas if you like them upstanding pious you know figure of rectitude serious moral all of that sort of stuff then you you turn to gladstone and they still those archetypes still have attraction because i mean i think that it those archetypes are kind of present whenever um johnson stands up to confront starmer prime minister's question time and i think that they're also there in the ongoing clash in Edinburgh between Alex Salmond and Nicola Sturgeon. I think that these are, if you like, the kind of timeless archetypes of British politics. It's roundheads and cavaliers ultimately, isn't it?
爱国、有点侠盗风范且有点狡猾的历史人物，那么迪斯雷利就是你的首选。而如果你喜欢他们正直、虔诚、你知道的，那种正派、严肃、道德高尚的人物，那么你就会转向格莱斯顿。这些原型依然具有吸引力，因为我认为，无论约翰逊何时站起来对抗斯塔默（Starmer）进行首相问答环节，这些原型都以某种方式存在。我认为它们也存在于爱丁堡亚历克斯·萨蒙德（Alex Salmond）和尼古拉·斯特金（Nicola Sturgeon）之间持续的冲突中。我认为这些，如果你愿意的话，是英国政治中永恒的原型。归根结底是圆颅党和骑士党，不是吗？
I mean, going all the way back. So, yes, definitely a match for the ages so we talked about Disraeli in um the first episode which uh has gone out already and I hope you've already listened to if you haven't and you want to know more about Disraeli do check that out um so let's get on to Gladstone who really was the star performer I think I mean I think he captured the imaginations of sports fans not just here in Britain but around the world with his progress, because every match was tough, hard, gruelling, and Gladstone emerged from it. Just as you might expect, this is a man who relaxed by chopping down trees. Yeah, translating Homer.
我的意思是，追溯到很久以前。所以，是的，这绝对是一场世纪对决。我们在第一集中谈到了迪斯雷利，那一集已经播出了，我希望你已经听过了。如果你还没听过，想了解更多关于迪斯雷利的信息，一定要去听听。那么，让我们进入格莱斯顿，我认为他确实是表现最出色的明星。我的意思是，我认为他凭借自己的表现抓住了体育迷们的想象力，不仅是在英国，而且是在全世界。因为每一场比赛都很艰难、艰苦、令人筋疲力尽，而格莱斯顿从中脱颖而出。正如你所料，这是一个通过砍树来放松的人。是的，翻译荷马史诗。
Translating Homer. This is a man who, yes, who takes his fun in a kind of tough, earnest way. And that's essentially at this level of sport is what you need, isn't it? Yeah. I mean, the thing with Gladstone, Gladstone absolutely incarnates the Victorian age, doesn't he? He is Victorianism because he's so stiff and he's so, I mean, he's the grand old man, the GOM. Although Victoria hated him, which is always. Queen Victoria said she addressed
翻译荷马史诗。这是一个，是的，以一种强硬、严肃的方式来享受乐趣的人。而在这种水平的体育竞技中，这正是你所需要的，不是吗？是的。我的意思是，格莱斯顿的问题在于，他绝对是维多利亚时代的化身，不是吗？他就是维多利亚主义，因为他太刻板了，我的意思是，他是“伟大的老人物”（GOM）。尽管维多利亚女王讨厌他，这总是……维多利亚女王说她对他说话
him as though she were a public meeting and and actually many of his own colleagues you know he's one of those characters that he's a monster in many ways he's a sort of titanic monster he's one of those characters like margaret thatcher or like nelson or like churchill or henry the eighth who's sort of larger than life that supremely got it suffused with a sense of their own importance and sees themselves as kind of- And justifies it. Yeah, and justifies it and sees themselves as incarnating the spirit of the age, which he does. I mean, if you think about recent books on the Victorian, so Simon Heffer wrote a book a couple
就像在面对一场公开会议一样。实际上，他自己的许多同事，你知道，他是那种在许多方面都是个怪物的人。他是一个泰坦般的怪物，就像玛格丽特·撒切尔、纳尔逊、丘吉尔或亨利八世一样，是那种超越常人、极其自负、沉浸在自我重要性中，并将自己视为……并且为此辩护的人。是的，并且为此辩护，并将自己视为时代精神的化身，他确实做到了。我的意思是，如果你想想最近关于维多利亚时代的书，西蒙·赫弗（Simon Heffer）几年前写了一本名为《高尚思想》（High Minds）的书，讲述了英国政治中的格莱斯顿时刻，他在书中说这是英国公共服务的一个高峰。而格莱斯顿就是这种精神的化身。你知道，格莱斯顿有一种强烈的基督教责任感，这反映在他所有的公务员改革和所有这类事情中。但当然，这也反映在格莱斯顿身上每个人都记得的另一件事上，那就是骚扰性工作者。
of years ago called High Minds about the sort of Gladstonian moment in British politics, in which he says this was a sort of high point of British public service. And Gladstone incarnates that. You know, Gladstone has this tremendous sense of Christian duty, which is, you know, reflected in all his civil service reforms and all that sort of thing. But, of course, it's also reflected in the other thing about Gladstone that everybody remembers, which is the bothering of sex workers.
好吧，你称之为骚扰。其他人可能会称之为改革。是的。好吧，改革。我的意思是，看，这现在太敏感了，不是吗？我的意思是，也许人们不想被改革，或者也许他们不需要。他们并没有堕落，也不需要被救赎。但无论如何，正如很多人所知道的，格莱斯顿会，你知道，去……乔装打扮走在
Well, you call it bothering. Others might call it reforming. Yes. Well, reforming. I mean, see, that's so loaded now, isn't it? I mean, maybe people don't want to be reformed or maybe they don't need to be. They're not fallen and they don't need to be redeemed. But anyway, as a lot of people will know gladstone would you know go sort of tram the
街上，试图去改革他遇到的妓女，然后他会回家，他会鞭打自己。是的，嗯，对于那些欣赏人类怪癖的人来说，这是一个美妙的心理时刻。但这也让你感受到了这个男人那种强烈、受折磨的心理。但是，我的意思是，我不认为他等同于那种自称是女权主义者，结果却是个性骚扰者的家伙。不，不，不，不。你知道，这是一种陈词滥调。我的意思是，他确实想为那些堕落的女性做善事，让她们得到救赎。
streets incognito to um try and sort of reform uh prostitutes that he met on the streets and then he'd go back home and he would beat himself yeah um and that is a you know it's a delicious kind of psychological moment for people who appreciate human quirks. But it also gives you a sense of the sort of intense, tortured psychology of the man. But, I mean, I don't think he's equivalent of kind of, you know, the self-proclaimed feminist guy who then turns out to be a sex pest that you might get. No, no, no, no. You know, it's kind of a trope to say. I mean, he really did want to do good by the redeemed fallen women.
他并没有猥亵或非礼她们。我的意思是，迪斯雷利不是说过他没有一个值得救赎的缺点吗？这确实总结了他的一切。我的意思是，他几乎太……他的正直令人压抑。确实令人压抑。我认为随着时间的推移，他的许多同事都有这种感觉。所以有各种关于他们的描述，到了1890年代，他的自由党内阁同事，通常是年轻的那一代。我的意思是，对他们来说，格莱斯顿是“伟大的老人物”。
He wasn't molesting them or groping them. And I mean, Disraeli, isn't it, who says that he had not a single redeeming defect, which kind of sums him up, really. I mean, he's almost too, his rectitude is oppressive. It is oppressive. And I think a lot of people, I think a lot of his colleagues found that as time went on. So there's all these accounts of them sort of by the 1890s, his Liberal cabinet colleagues, often the younger ones. I mean, Gladstone is to them the grand old man.
他们确实感到被他压迫。就像和校长坐在一张桌子旁一样。是的。被他压迫。就像和校长坐在一张桌子旁一样。而且，你知道，当他离开办公室时，他们中的一些人，很多人都泪流满面。我的意思是，这就像斯大林去世时俄罗斯的那种场景。他们很高兴，但他们忍不住
They really do feel oppressed by him. It's like being sat around a table with the headmaster. Yes. by him. It's like being sat around a table with the headmaster. And, you know, when he goes, when he finally leaves office, some of them, a lot of them are in floods of tears. I mean, it's like those sort of scenes in Russia when Stalin died or something. They're delighted, but they can't help
啜泣，因为这似乎是英国生活中一个伟大的支柱消失了。但是当然，多米尼克，格莱斯顿也曾年轻过。年轻时，我的意思是，他不仅是保守党人，还是一个反动的保守党人。他非常热衷于维护，例如，爱尔兰国教的权利。是的。当然，从长远来看，他最出名的是他推动给予爱尔兰自治权的尝试。我觉得在那场比赛中非常有趣的是，有来自爱尔兰的人引用迪斯雷利的话，迪斯雷利对爱尔兰人非常恶毒，他们说，让我们支持格莱斯顿。
sobbing because it seems like this great fixture of British life has disappeared. But of course, Dominic, there was a time where Gladstone was a young man. And as a young man, he was, I mean, he wasn't just a Tory, he was a reactionary Tory. And he was very keen on upholding, for instance, the rights of the established church in Ireland. Yes. And of course, in the long run, what he becomes most famous for is his pushing through attempt to give Ireland home rule. And I thought that it was really interesting in this match. There were people from Ireland quoting Disraeli, who was incredibly abusive about the Irish and saying, let's get behind Gladstone.
所以，是的，我看到我们有大量的爱尔兰选票，不是吗？是的，我们没有……这太有趣了，格莱斯顿最近上了新闻，因为他被利物浦大学“取消”了。所以他的名字被移除了。他是利物浦伟大的儿子，他们最著名的儿子之一，他的名字被从利物浦的一栋宿舍楼上移除了，尽管学生们希望他留下来，
So, yeah, I saw that we had a flood of Irish votes, didn't we? Yes, we didn't have, which is so interesting, is that Gladstone has been in the news recently because he's been cancelled by Liverpool University. So his name has been taken. He's a great son of Liverpool, one of their most famous sons, and his name has been taken off a hall of residence at Liverpool, despite the fact that the students want him to stay
而且许多学者认为移除他的名字是荒谬的。因为当他还是个非常年轻的人时，他基本上为他家族的……他试图捍卫他家族在加勒比地区的殖民利益，他们在那里拥有种植园。尽管后来，当然，他成为了这位伟大的改革家和各种进步事业的捍卫者，但那种早期代表他家族的失误在利物浦大学当局眼中毁了他。所以他的名字被从这栋楼上移除了。我认为有趣的是，这反映了今天的人们可能难以理解格莱斯顿所处的基督教背景。因为当然，在某种意义上，他的一生都是为了试图为他后来所认为的早期错误获得救赎，而格莱斯顿
and a lot of the academics think it's ridiculous to take his name off. Because when he was a very young man, he basically spoke up for his family's – he tried to defend his family's colonial interests in the Caribbean where they owned plantations. And even though later on, of course, he became this great reformer and a champion of every conceivable progressive cause, that early sort of misstep on behalf of his family has damned him in the eyes of the University of Liverpool authorities. And so his name has been taken off this hall. And I think that what's interesting about that is that it reflects the way in which people today perhaps have difficulty in understanding the Christian context in which Gladstone is absolutely situated. Because of course, there's a sense in which his entire life is an attempt to kind of gain redemption for his what he comes to see as his early faults and gladstone is
绝对是一个相信罪恶、相信救赎的人，在某种意义上，他的整个职业生涯都是对此的纪念。这是一个人们可以相信这些的时代。现在我们没有那种感觉了。我想，我想那是真的，而且我认为实际上，这就是为什么——我知道这听起来是一个极其琐碎的事情——为什么在这个极其不重要的比赛中，他确实抓住了人们的想象力，因为他在某种程度上是一个看起来最不合时宜、离我们最远的人物。所以，你知道，18世纪的那些人物，他们都相当……我的意思是，我讨厌使用这种术语，但用奥普拉·温弗瑞（Oprah Winfrey）的话说，是“可共情的”。但格莱斯顿非常不可共情。
absolutely a man who believes in sin believes in redemption and in a sense his entire career is a monument to that and this is an age where people can believe in that now we don't have that sense i think i think that's true and i think actually that's one reason i know it sounds like a stupidly trivial thing to say but one reason why in this immensely unimportant contest he actually did get people's imaginations because he is a he is in some ways the figure who seems most out of time who seems fur furthest from us. So, you know, the sort of 18th century figures, they're all quite, I mean, I hate to use this sort of jargon, but relatable, as Oprah Winfrey would no doubt say. But Gladstone is very unrelatable.
我的意思是，我们已经完全失去了那种，你知道，严肃性。是的，还有那种肌肉基督教。那个家伙认为他有空闲时间，你知道，他不会去查看手机什么的。他会去砍些木头，翻译一些……有一个理由说，实际上格莱斯顿在某种程度上是比任何人都更能创造现代英国政治的首相？我的意思是，他是伟大的财政大臣。
I mean, we've completely lost touch with that sort of, you know. Earnestness. Yeah, and that sort of muscular Christianity. The guy who thinks he's got a spare moment, you know, he's not going to check his phone or something. He's going to go and chop some logs and translate some a case to be said that actually Gladstone, in a way, is the prime minister more than anyone else who essentially creates British politics as it exists now? I mean, he's the great chancellor.
我的意思是，他基本上创造了现在存在的财政大臣这一角色。他改革了公务员制度，改革了军队，所有这些事情。在某种意义上，他创造了现代英国。而且实际上不仅如此，汤姆。
I mean, he essentially creates the role of the chancellorship of the exchequer as it exists now. He reforms the civil service, reforms the army, all these kinds of things. And in a sense, he reforms the civil service, reforms the army, all these kind of things. And in a sense, he creates modern Britain. And actually more than that, Tom.
所以我确实认为，通过公务员改革等等以及军队改革，他给了我们一个进入20世纪的现代国家。但甚至在此之外，他给了我们政治，即一种具有某种大众参与元素的东西。所以格莱斯顿的米德洛锡安竞选（Midlothian campaign）是关于保加利亚暴行的竞选，当时他会……我的意思是，格莱斯顿会向那些庞大的人群发表演讲，其中大多数人根本听不清他在说什么，但他们仍然会被那一刻所吸引。那种伟大的政治家走上街头，发表像杰里米·科尔宾（Jeremy Corbyn）风格的演讲，是格莱斯顿真正开创了这一点。
So I do think that with the civil service reform and so on and the army reform is he gives us a modern state to take into the 20th century. But even beyond that, he gives us politics in the sense of something that you do that has a kind of mass participatory element so gladstone's midlothian campaign is campaigning about atrocities in bulgaria when he would i mean gladstone would speak to these colossal crowds most of him could not hear a word he was saying and who would yet be entranced by the moment and that sense of the great politician taking to the streets and addressing mass you you know, sort of, oh, Jeremy Corbyn-style meetings. It's Gladstone who really pioneers that.
所以格莱斯顿不仅创造了后世的治国方略，他还创造了选举政治。然后他被地铁送去参加葬礼。是这样吗？那是一个伟大的事实。我相信是这样。我想我是从酒吧问答中学到的。这可能不是真的，但我会把它塞进去。
So Gladstone creates not just sort of the statecraft of later ages, but he creates the electoral politics as well. And then he gets taken to his funeral by tube. Is that so? That is a great fact. I believe so. I think I learned that from a pub quiz. It may not be true, but I'll just smuggle that in.
是的。无论如何，这就是格莱斯顿对阵迪斯雷利。激动人心的比赛。格莱斯顿最终以54%的得票率获胜。然后我们进行了皮尔（Peel）对阵小皮特（Pitt the Younger）的比赛。我们在上一集中谈论过他们。小皮特以54%的得票率获胜。又是同样的获胜优势。
Yeah. Anyway, so that was Gladstone against Israeli. Thrilling match. Gladstone ended up winning it by 54%. We then had Peel against Pitt the Younger. We've talked about them in the previous episode. Pitt the Younger won that 54%. Again, so same margin of victory.
是的。我的意思是，皮特总是会赢的，不是吗？皮尔的《谷物法》和他创建的“鲍比”（Bobby，指警察）并不是……当然，现在，对皮尔来说非常不幸的是，那次投票发生在那天警察让自己蒙羞之后。哦，是的。在伦敦。在克拉珀姆公社（Clapham Common），是的。
Yes. I mean, Pitt was always going to win that, wasn't he? Peel's Corn Laws and his Bobby creating were not. And, of course, that now, and very unfortunate for Peel, that vote took place the day after the police had disgraced themselves. Oh, yes. In London. At Clapham Common, yes.
在克拉珀姆公社，为莎拉·埃弗拉德（Sarah Everard）举行的守夜活动。所以创建警察部队可能……不，这不会让选民喜欢他。所以接下来我们进行了……自由左翼之间的冲突，劳合·乔治（Lloyd George）对阵艾德礼（Attlee），我们还没有真正谈论过这两位20世纪的泰坦级人物。所以让我们先谈谈劳合·乔治，他当然在阿斯奎斯（Asquith）政府中。阿斯奎斯淘汰了撒切尔。所以我们简要谈论了那个自由党政府。但谈到格莱斯顿为现代英国国家奠定基础，在某种意义上，阿斯奎斯政府，其中劳合·乔治是关键人物，他们确实奠定了基础
At Clapham Common, the vigil for Sarah Everard. So creating the police not perhaps uh no it was not um going to adhere itself to the voters so then we had um a clash between those on the liberal left um lloyd george against atlee and we haven't really talked about either of those two titanic figures of 20 20th century. So let's talk about Lloyd George first, who of course was in Asquith's government. Asquith knocked out Thatcher. So we've talked briefly about that liberal government. But having talked about Gladstone laying the foundations for the modern British state, in a sense, the Asquith government, in which Lloyd George was kind of the key player, they are really laying the foundations
福利国家，不是吗？他们确实。好吧，他们创造了一个福利国家。我的意思是，福利国家并不是在1940年代才创造出来的。福利国家已经存在了。那么劳合·乔治在其中扮演什么角色？所以劳合·乔治是财政大臣。劳合·乔治是阿斯奎斯的财政大臣。
for the welfare state, aren't they? They are. Well, they create a welfare state. I mean, the welfare state wasn't created in the 1940s. There was a welfare state already. So what's Lloyd George's role in that? So Lloyd George is chancellor. Lloyd George is Asquith's Chancellor.
劳合·乔治想要养老金之类的东西。他想要增加政府的权力。劳合·乔治和阿斯奎斯一起。而且他想摆脱公爵，不是吗？公爵，是的。他对公爵非常敌视，因为他们的花费和一艘无畏舰一样多。因为你看，他们被上议院阻挠了。所以上议院是由保守党控制的。
Lloyd George wants things like pensions. He wants to increase the power of government. Lloyd George and Asquith together. And he wants to get rid of dukes, doesn't he? Dukes, yes. He's very hostile to dukes because they cost as much as a dreadnought. Because they're being blocked, you see, by the House of Lords. So the House of Lords is Tory-dominated.
上议院决心阻止税收的增加以及新自由党政府提供的养老金和福利的增加。所以你在20世纪初看到的是格莱斯顿式的自由主义，即自由放任、自由市场、不干涉、小政府，而阿斯奎斯和劳合·乔治的新自由主义者，你知道，想要一种福利国家，他们是更积极的政府，在许多方面为我们所认为的战后工党政治奠定了基础。当然，没有人记得这一点的原因是因为自由党在这两个人之间分裂了，变得在选举上无关紧要，所以自那以后他们没有真正的选民基础来为我们记住他们而争论。
And the House of Lords is determined to block the rise in taxes and the increase in things like um pensions and benefits that the new the liberal government are offering so what you've got in the early 20th century you've had gladstonian liberalism which is all laissez-faire kind of free market hands-off small government and the new liberals of asquith and lloyd george you know want a kind of welfare state they're much more activist government laying the foundation in many ways for what we'd think of as the sort of post-war labor politics and the reason that nobody remembers this of course is because the liberal party splits between these two men yeah becomes electorally irrelevant so they have no real constituency since then arguing for us to remember them.
然而在当时，在20世纪的前20年，可能前30年，阿斯奎斯和劳合·乔治是这些巨大的数字。我的意思是，特别是劳合·乔治。人们在政治上定义自己是基于他们与劳合·乔治的关系。他是那个时代的风向标。所以劳合·乔治，除了基本上资助这种新兴的福利国家、养老金等等之外，他还在为无畏舰筹集资金。
And yet at the time, in the first 20 years of the – really, probably the first 30 years of the 20th century, Asquith and Lloyd George are these massive figures. I mean, Lloyd George in particular. People defined themselves politically by where they stood in relation to Lloyd George. He was the weathermaker. And so Lloyd George, as well as basically funding this kind of emergent welfare state, pensions and so on, he's also finding the money for dreadnoughts.
是的。基本上赋予了英国海军力量，使其能够坚持度过第一次世界大战。然后他成为了首相。基本上阿斯奎斯太悠闲了，他忙着和他的女朋友们打桥牌，所以劳合·乔治以联合政府首脑的身份上台，是一位战时领袖，一位成功的战时领袖，他代表英国参加了凡尔赛条约，他确实做到了，所以他是一个非常重要的人物。
Yes. Essentially giving Britain's naval power, the ability to hold out through the first world war. And then he becomes prime minister. Basically Asquith is just kind of too laid back he's hanging out playing bridge with his girlfriends yeah so lloyd george comes in at the head of a coalition um is a war leader a successful war leader he represents britain at the treaty of versailles he does um and so he's a hugely significant figure
但是，然而，是的，是的，有各种各样的……所以劳合·乔治是……所以劳合·乔治是一个……他确实是个怪物。我的意思是，向威尔士和自由党的听众道歉，但我认为劳合·乔治是个彻头彻尾的怪物。在上一期播客中，我们谈到了英国政治中的江湖骗子倾向，正如现在正如即使是他的崇拜者也会承认的那样，由鲍里斯·约翰逊（Boris Johnson）所体现。
but however yes yes there's all sorts of that so lloyd george is the most so lloyd george is a And so he's a hugely significant figure. But, but, but. However, yes. There's all sorts of buts. So Lloyd George is the most, so Lloyd George is a, it really is a monster. I mean, apologies to sort of Welsh and liberal listeners, but I think Lloyd George is an utter monster. In the last podcast, we were talking about the mountebank tendency in British politics as now incarnated, as surely even his admirers would admit by Boris Johnson.
而劳合·乔治就是那种江湖骗子。所以阿斯奎斯在第一次世界大战前的马可尼丑闻中把劳合·乔治从耻辱中拯救了出来，当时劳合·乔治是……这是一种内幕交易。股票内幕交易。劳合·乔治来自威尔士一个相对卑微的背景，他总是对他的妻子和其他人说，我唯一的野心就是出人头地。
And Lloyd George is the kind of mountebank. So Asquith had saved Lloyd George from disgrace in the Marconi scandal before the First World War when Lloyd George was... Which is kind of insider dealing. Insider dealing in shares. Lloyd George came from this sort of relatively humble background in Wales, and he always said to his wife and to other people, my only ambition is to get on.
所以他最初是一个激进派，我不怀疑他的激进主义是真诚的。但实际上，在1910年代的过程中，他抛弃了这一点。所以他最终成为了一个基本上由保守党控制的政府的首脑。他卖官鬻爵。所以他在经济上极其腐败。他建立了一个政治基金，拒绝与其他自由党人分享，这非常糟糕。但以今天的标准来看，更糟糕的是他的性道德。我的意思是，劳合·乔治，人们称他为“山羊”，他真的不是一个你会……
So he starts out as a radical, and I don't doubt that his radicalism was genuinely believed. But he sheds that, actually, in the course of the 1910s. So he ends up as the head of basically a Tory-dominated government. He sells peerages for cash. So he's incredibly financially crooked. And he builds up this political fund that he refuses to share with other liberals, which is pretty bad. But what is worse by today's standards is his sexual morality. I mean, Lloyd George, people call him the goat, and he really isn't a man that you would...
“羊蹄吟游诗人”，不是吗？多曼·阿奎因（Domain Arquines）这样描述他，这……这让他听起来像个相当浪漫的人物。他基本上是一个非正式的重婚者。所以他在家里有妻子，在伦敦有他的秘书或他的“政治妻子”弗朗西斯·史蒂文森（Frances Stevenson）。但是，你知道，没有女人是安全的，包括他自己的儿媳，我认为这跨越了各种不应该跨越的界限。所以他儿子的妻子。
The goat-footed bard, wasn't it? Domain Arquines described him as, which is... It kind of makes him sound quite a romantic figure. He's basically a kind of informal bigamist. So he's got his wife at home and he's got his secretary or his sort of political wife, Frances Stevenson, in London. But, you know, no woman is safe, including his own daughter-in-law, which I think crosses various lines that shouldn't really be crossed. So his son's wife.
我认为在1920年代初，在整个政治光谱中，人们普遍认为他只是个坏人。他的一位助手说，他拥有我见过的最大的器官。是的，那是……是的，在更衣室里……如果这是衡量成功的标准，劳合·乔治可能会赢……是的，但话虽如此，还有所有这些，当然，进入30年代，事实是他实际上非常喜欢希特勒。他是。是的，我认为这部分是因为劳合·乔治有这个……我认为他的政治愿景是——
And I think that there was definitely a point in the early 1920s when, quite widespread across the political spectrum there was a sense that he's just a bad man one of his aides said that he he had the biggest organ i've ever seen yes that's so yeah in the changing rooms um my george might win on that if that was if that was one measure of success um yeah but so that said there's all that and then of course moving into the 30s there's the fact that he's actually quite keen on Hitler. He is. Yes, and I think that's partly because Lloyd George has this – his vision of politics, I think, is –
它是由像他自己这样的人定义的，狂暴、有动力、极具魅力的伟人。这就是为什么他和丘吉尔是好朋友。丘吉尔和劳合·乔治在1900年代和1910年代是好朋友，在某些方面，劳合·乔治是丘吉尔的榜样，你知道，他是一个被恶魔般的冲动所驱动的人，你知道，他坚持认为他可以按照自己的模子重塑国家。劳合·乔治看向国外，他看向墨索里尼和希特勒这样的人，他说，好吧，这些人显然是像我一样的伟人。他们是这些了不起的演说家，所有这些东西。
that it's defined by people like himself, tempestuous, driven, incredibly charismatic great men. So that's why he's such friends with Churchill Churchill and Lloyd George were great pals in the 1900s and 1910s and in some ways Lloyd George is a model for Churchill you know he's a man powered by demonic urges you know who insists thinks he can remake the country in his own mold and Lloyd George looks abroad and he looks at people like Mussolini and Hitler and he says well well, these are clearly great men like me. They are these tremendous speakers and all this sort of stuff.
而且有一些说法，你知道，劳合·乔治的党徒会因为我这么说而鄙视我，但有一些说法称，如果英国在第二次世界大战初期的情况不同，如果我们不得不进行某种贝当（Marshall Pétain）式的安排，劳合·乔治将是一个显而易见的人选。他毫无原则，完全没有原则。
And there is some talk, you know, Lloyd George's partisans will despise me for saying this, but there is some talk that had things gone otherwise for Britain at the beginning of the second world war, had we had to do a kind of Marshall Payton style arrangement, Lloyd George would have been an obvious man to step in. He's unprincipled, completely unprincipled.
他，就像法国的贝当一样，他会对自己说，我是英雄，我是国家的救星，我还要再次拯救国家。所以，我的意思是，也许我们不应该因为这没有发生而对他怀恨在心。但我认为劳合·乔治和他的许多批评者，例如他的保守党批评者，
He, like Payton in France, he would say to himself, I'm a hero, I'm the saviour of the country, I'm going to save the country yet again. So, I mean, maybe we shouldn't hold that against him because it didn't happen. But I think there was always the potential there with Lloyd George and a lot of his critics, you know, his Tory critics, for example,
像斯坦利·鲍德温（Stanley Baldwin）这样的人，总是存在这种潜力，他们认为他是一个危险的人，一个拥有巨大能力和潜力的人，但很狡猾。好吧，这在某种程度上是你可能想要的一个伟大的运动员所具备的，一种召唤危险感的能力。你把他看作是英国的马拉多纳……是的，一种马拉多纳式的品质。
people like Stanley Baldwin, they saw him as a dangerous man, a man of enormous ability and potential, but dodgy. Okay, which in a way is kind of what you want in a great sportsman, perhaps, an ability to conjure a sense of danger. You see him as the Maradona of British... Yes, a Maradona-esque quality.
他在四分之一决赛中对阵克莱门特·艾德礼（Clement Attlee）。艾德礼和丘吉尔，20世纪中叶的两位伟大的泰坦，他们是，我想是什么？是的。19世纪中叶之后的迪斯雷利和格莱斯顿。我们还没有真正谈论过他们。而且这两个人在
He was up against Clement Attlee in the quarterfinal. And Attlee and Churchill, the two great titans of the mid-20th century, they are, I guess, what? Yeah. The Israeli and Gladstone after the mid-90th century. We haven't really talked about them yet. And both men have crucial roles to play
英国首相世界杯的戏剧性和兴奋感中都发挥了关键作用。所以让我们现在休息一下，回来后我们将回顾四分之一决赛的最后两场比赛、半决赛和决赛，我们将特别关注艾德礼和丘吉尔。我们稍后见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐界的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com，那是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》，我们正在剖析《历史的余味》世界杯，那个
in the drama and excitement of the way that that the prime minister british prime minister world cup worked out so let's take a break now and then when we come back we'll go through the the last two matches of the quarterfinals the semifinals and the final and we'll have a particular focus on atlee and churchill we'll see you then i'm marina hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com that's therestisentertainment.com welcome back to the rest is history and we are dissecting the rest is history world cup that
国际体育日历上的固定赛事。我们进展得如此顺利和专业，以至于我们已经进行到第三场四分之一决赛的一半了。我们讨论了其中一位四分之一决赛选手，即劳合·乔治。我们现在想谈谈他的对手，克莱门特·艾德礼。所以丘吉尔和艾德礼，正如你所说，汤姆，他们是20世纪中叶的巨大人物，不是吗？但对我来说，我的意思是，显然，丘吉尔，每个人都知道温斯顿·丘吉尔。他在钱币上。你知道，有他的雕像。他是大众想象力的一部分。
fixture of the international sporting calendar we're making such smooth and professional progress that we are halfway through the third quarterfinal. We've discussed one of the quarterfinalists, which is Lloyd George. And we now want to his opponent, who is Clement Attlee, and we want to talk about. So Churchill and Attlee, they are, as you said, Tom, they are huge kind of mid-century figures, aren't they? But for me, I mean, obviously, Churchill is, everybody knows Winston Churchill. He's on the money. You know, there's a statue of him. He is part of the popular imagination.
而克莱门特·艾德礼，如果你对政治不感兴趣，如果你不是左翼，如果你对现代历史不太感兴趣，他会更匿名一些，不是吗？但这就是关于他一直流传的著名说法，不是吗？是什么？一辆空出租车停下，克莱门特·艾德礼走下来，这是丘吉尔被认为说过的话，但从未说过。丘吉尔没说过。他没说。丘吉尔非常钦佩他，他确实称赞他是一位爱国者。是的，有一个故事说，一个年轻的保守党新秀来到查特韦尔（Chartwell），试图讨好丘吉尔，抨击艾德礼。丘吉尔说，你知道，如果你还想再来查特韦尔，你永远不会
And Clement Attlee, if you're not interested in politics, if you're not left wing, and if you're not terribly interested in modern history, he's a bit more anonymous, isn't he? But that's the famous thing that was always said about him, wasn't it? What was it an empty car a right empty taxi drew up and clement atley got out which is churchill is supposed to have said and never said churchill didn't say it he didn't say churchill was a great admirer of him and he was indeed so this praised him as a patriot yeah there's a story that a tour young tory tyro comes to chartwell and sort of opens a curry favour with Churchill, sort of lays into Attlee. And Churchill says, you know, if you ever want to come to Chartwell again, you will never
说这种关于……哦，你永远不会在我的面前谈论愚蠢的老艾德礼。艾德礼先生是一位伟人，是一位爱国者。当然，当丘吉尔去世时，艾德礼说了非常温暖的话，我一直认为，如果你是丘吉尔的捍卫者，我的意思是，这应该是你首先提出来的事情之一，当他去世时，艾德礼说，我们失去了我们时代最伟大的英国人。事实上，我们时代最伟大的世界公民。好吧，我想他们都在赢得战争的联合政府中，不是吗？所以从这个意义上说，他们是同志。所以……艾德礼去了黑利伯里（Haileybury），那是那所公立学校，基本上是为了送人去管理印度，是的，大英帝国……而且他一直服务于学院，是的，而且他非常喜欢它。
say such silly things about, oh, you'll never talk about silly old Attlee in my presence. Mr. Attlee is a great man and a patriot. And of course, Attlee said incredibly warm things about Churchill when Churchill died, which I always think is one of the, if you're a Churchill defender, I mean, that should be one of the sort of first things that you bring out, that when he died, Attlee said, we've lost the greatest Englishman of our time. In fact, the greatest citizen of the world of our time. Well, I suppose they were both in the coalition, weren't they, that won the war so in that sense kind of comrades so so um atley is he goes to haylerbury which is the public school that um essentially exists to send people to run india yes the british empire um and he always services college yeah yes and he he's he's very fond of it.
然后，在这一点上，我猜他只是一个，你知道，一个保守党人，年轻的保守党人。然后他去了伦敦东区，他经历了一次大马士革式的转变。是的，他经历了。而且他……所以艾德礼有这种非凡的……约翰·比尤（John Bew）写过——他是鲍里斯·约翰逊外交政策的顾问——《公民克莱姆》（Citizen Clem）。写了这本关于艾德礼的精彩传记。艾德礼是一个非常有趣且令人钦佩的人，因为正如你所说，他完全是一个传统的、公立学校出身的保守党男孩。但他确实有一种……留着小胡子，抽着烟斗，喜欢板球，虽然打得不太好。
And then he, at this point, I'm guessing he's just a kind of, you know, he's a Tory guy, Tory young man. And then he goes to the East End and he has a Damascene conversion. Yes, he does. And he, so Attlee has this extraordinary, John Bew has written – who's Boris Johnson's foreign policy kind of advisor. Citizen Clem. Has written this fantastic biography of Attlee. Attlee is a fantastically interesting and admirable man because, as you say, he's completely conventional, public school boy, dory. But he does have a sense of – Butchempa moustache and pipe and loves cricket, not very good at it.
对他有很多同感。不过你没有胡子，汤姆。我觉得留胡子你会看起来更帅。不，我不会。我不会。但我认为我们的板球记录非常相似。我觉得你会看起来很像特里·托马斯（Terry Thomas）。你好。
A lot of fellow feeling for him. You don't have the moustache though, Tom. I think you'd look smarter with a moustache. No, I don't. I don't. But I think our cricket record is very similar. I think you'd look very Terry Thomas. Hello.
无论如何，那是题外话。淋浴。所以艾德礼，他有一种令人难以置信的公共服务道德，嗯，他确实去了伦敦东区，参与照顾贫困儿童，这激发了他的社会主义思想。他是一个没有基督教信仰的基督教社会主义者，正如他后来自己所说，你知道，嗯，我相信所有的道德。我受不了那些胡言乱语。这就是他那种驱动性的激情。但与此同时，艾德礼的爱国主义是根深蒂固的。这部分是因为我认为他参加了第一次世界大战。
Anyway, that's by the by. Shower. So Attlee, he has this incredible ethic of public service and um he does he goes to the east end of london and he gets involved with looking after kind of poor kids and that that fuels his socialism he's a christian socialist without the christianity as he says himself later on you know um i believe in all ethics. I can't stand the mumbo jumbo. And that's his sort of driving passion. But at the same time, the patriotism with Attlee is incredibly deep seated. And that's partly, I think, because he fights in the First World War.
他是少校，不是吗？艾德礼少校。他在加里波利（Gallipoli）。我想他臀部中弹了。当他们撤离时，他是苏拉湾（Suvla Bay）撤出的第二个人，然后他在美索不达米亚作战，
He's a major, isn't he? Major Attlee. He's in Gallipoli. He's shot in the buttocks, I think it is. He's the second man out of Suvla Bay at Gallipoli when they were evacuated he then fights in Mesopotamia
然后他因伤退役，所以他是一个有着无可挑剔战争记录的人，这就是为什么人们称他为“艾德礼少校”。我的意思是，那个时代的人确实以那种战争记录为荣，这就是为什么他一直让我感到亲切。
and he's invalided out so he is somebody with an impeccable war record that's why people call him Major Attlee I mean people in those days did trade on that war record and that's what has always endeared him
我认为对于政治光谱两边的人来说，另一个人对此也非常温暖的是玛格丽特·撒切尔。在她的回忆录中，她说，多么伟大的首相……你知道，她不同意他的政策，但他是多么伟大的人，伟大的工党人，伟大的工党。她实际上说，在1979年的选举中，当她竞选第一任首相时，当她站出来时，她说她呼吁那些投票给艾德礼的工党人。她说，你知道，因为那个原因来投票给我。所以1979年被视为一个关键的变革性选举，而撒切尔被视为一位变革性的首相。而艾德礼有，你知道，我的意思是，他有类似的地位。
I think to people on both sides of the political spectrum so somebody else who's very warm about that is margaret thatcher in her memoir she says what a tremendous prime you know what she didn't agree with him in his policies but what a tremendous man he was great labor man great labor and she actually says that in the 1979 election when she's running for her first term as prime minister, when she's standing, then she says she appeals to Labour people who voted for Attlee. She says, you know, come and vote for me because of that reason. So 1979 is seen as a kind of key transformative election and Thatcher as a transformative prime minister. And Attlee has, you know, I mean, he has a similar status.
所以1945年的选举和随之而来的工党政府。这就是艾德礼声誉的基础。他是主持福利国家建立的人。我想我们已经看过了格莱斯顿和劳合·乔治在其中扮演的角色。所以这比艾德礼进来从零开始创造它要复杂得多。但他在建立国家医疗服务体系（NHS）和福利国家方面的作用是关键的，不是吗？那是关键。那三个字母，NHS。
So 1945 election and the Labour government that comes in. This is what Attlee's reputation is founded on. That he is the man who presides over the creation of the welfare state. I guess that we've already looked at the role that Gladstone and Lloyd George kind of played in that. So it's slightly more complicated than Attlee comes in and creates it from scratch. But his role in creating the National Health Service and the welfare state is key, isn't it? That's the key. Those three letters, NHS.
而NHS显然已经成为英国人的一种世俗宗教。现在，英国听众会认为这是理所当然的。我们的海外听众此时会认为英国人崇拜一个医疗服务体系简直是疯了。但我们当然会。我的意思是，它出现在2012年奥运会开幕式上。而艾德礼作为NHS创始人的地位，或者作为主持其建立的人，
And the NHS has obviously become a kind of secular religion for British people. Now, British listeners will take that for granted. Our overseas listeners will think at this point the British are demented to worship a health service. But of course we do. I mean, it was in the Olympic ceremony, opening ceremony in 2012. And Attlee's status as the founder of the NHS or as the person who presided over its foundation
已经确立了他在政治传奇中的地位。而且我认为另一件事，汤姆，是工党自那时以来就没有一位让工党活动家真正感到非常自豪的首相。所以有1960年代和70年代的哈罗德·威尔逊（Harold Wilson），但当他离开时，他自己的许多活动家认为他是一个秘密的保守党人。托尼·布莱尔（Tony Blair），你知道，他的名声是众所周知的，
has enshrined his place in political legend. And I think the other thing, Tom, is that Labour have not had since then a prime minister of whom Labour activists are actually terribly proud. So there was Harold Wilson in the 1960s and 70s, but by the time he left, a lot of his own activists thought he was a crypto Tory. Tony Blair, who, you know, his reputation is well known,
而艾德礼是那道闪亮的光芒。所以艾德礼走了，但……艾德礼是，你知道，“艾德礼少校”，他在建立北约方面发挥了关键作用，他赞助了英国的核威慑力量，他基本上主持了印巴分治。我的意思是，他……所以从左翼的角度来看，他的名声上有污点。从左翼的角度来看，是的，绝对。而且我认为，我的意思是，
and Attlee is the one kind of shining light so at least gone but but um atlee is you know major atlee and he he's he plays a key role in setting up nato he sponsors the british nuclear deterrent um he essentially presides over partition. I mean, he... So there are blots on his escutcheon, seen from the left, from the perspective of the left. Seen from the left, yes, absolutely. And I think, I mean,
当他在1940年代和50年代担任首相时，他在自己的左翼中并不太受欢迎。实际上，关于艾德礼有趣的事情是，直到1990年代左右，如果你问人们谁是伟大的首相，艾德礼真的不会出现在名单上，事实上，在左翼和许多……
he wasn't terribly popular with his own left, actually, when he was prime minister in the 1940s and 50s. And actually, the funny thing about Attlee is that until about the 1990s, if you had said to people who are great prime ministers atlee wouldn't really have featured and in fact on the left and among a lot of sort of
事实上，他在20世纪40年代和50年代担任首相时，在左翼内部并不怎么受欢迎。有趣的是，关于艾德礼，直到20世纪90年代左右，如果你问人们谁是伟大的首相，艾德礼其实并不会被提及，事实上，在左翼和许多人看来
left-leaning academics a lot of the talk about the atlee government was wasted opportunities roads not taken right yeah um anthony howard the editor of the late it was at one point editor of the new statesman wrote an essay about the that period in which he said it was the greatest restoration of traditional values since 1660 of 1945. So this is classic Sandbrook punditry. Radical left-wing figures are rebranded as conservatives. But with the case of Attlee, he is clearly in some ways a very conservative, small C figure, as well as a very radically socialist figure. Yeah. Personally, he's very conservative, isn't he?
在左倾学者看来，关于艾德礼政府的许多讨论都是在谈论错失的机会和未走的路，对吧？嗯，安东尼·霍华德，已故的《新政治家》杂志编辑，曾写过一篇关于那个时期的文章，他说那是自1660年以来对传统价值观最伟大的恢复，即1945年。所以这就是典型的桑德布鲁克式评论。激进的左翼人物被重新包装成了保守派。但在艾德礼的案例中，他在某些方面显然是一个非常保守的、小写的“c”保守主义者，同时也是一个非常激进的社会主义者。是的。就个人而言，他非常保守，不是吗？
I mean, his love of – so, for example, they say to him, would you like a ticker tape machine in number 10? Dominic, being interested in cricket doesn't mean you're conservative. It just means you're interested in cricket. Oh, I'm not sure about that, Tom. I'm not sure. Because you're right. He used the ticker tape in cricket. Oh, I'm not sure about that, Tom. I'm not sure about that. Because you're right, yes. He used the ticker tape to get the cricket scores.
我的意思是，他热爱——比如，他们问他，你想在唐宁街10号放一台股票行情自动收录机吗？多米尼克，对板球感兴趣并不意味着你就是保守派。这只是意味着你对板球感兴趣。哦，我不确定，汤姆。我不确定。因为你是对的。他确实用那个收录机看板球比分。哦，我不确定，汤姆。我不确定。因为你是对的，是的。他用那个收录机来获取板球比分。
To get the cricket scores. And of course, nothing mattered more to him than his old school tie and Hayleybury. Right. You know, you mentioned the school. And we remember the school. We don't normally remember prime minister's schools. We remember it with him because it mattered so much to him. So a classically British mix of the conservative and the radical um yeah but perhaps
获取板球比分。当然，对他来说，没有什么比他的老校友领带和黑利伯里公学更重要的了。对。你知道，你提到了那所学校。我们都记得那所学校。我们通常不会记得首相们读过的学校。我们记得他的学校是因为它对他来说太重要了。所以这是一种典型的英国式混合体，既保守又激进，嗯，是的，但也许
because to a degree there is a sense of anonymity about him he's not a flamboyant figure and so therefore as he as as the real atlee fades from the historical memory he can become a kind of symbol which perhaps is is the role he's playing here that he's a symbol of the nhs he's a symbol of i think the welfare state i think he's actually you know that he's a symbol of the NHS. He's a symbol of the welfare state. I think he's actually, you know who he reminds me of, Tom? George Orwell. They're the same period. Yeah, yeah.
因为在某种程度上，他有一种匿名感，他不是一个浮夸的人物，所以当真正的艾德礼从历史记忆中淡去时，他可以成为一种象征，这也许就是他在这里扮演的角色，他是国民医疗服务体系（NHS）的象征，我认为他是福利国家的象征，我认为他实际上，你知道他让我想起了谁吗，汤姆？乔治·奥威尔。他们是同一个时期的人。是的，是的。
And they're both, you know, there are cases to be made from them from both sides of the spectrum. Conservatives hold up Attlee as their sort of, you know, patriotic labour man. All that, blue labour, exactly. And Ken Loach and people of that tendency talk about the spirit of 45 and the foundation of the nhs so everybody can find in the sort of the romanticized clement atlee so it's not surprising that that atlee should have beaten lloyd george quite
而且他们俩，你知道，在光谱的两端都有人为他们辩护。保守派把艾德礼视为他们那种，你知道，爱国的工党人。所有这些，蓝色工党，没错。而肯·洛奇和那些倾向的人谈论的是45年的精神和NHS的建立，所以每个人都能在某种浪漫化的克莱门特·艾德礼身上找到自己想要的东西，所以艾德礼能相当决定性地击败劳合·乔治也就不足为奇了
decisively 64 because lloyd george i think despite i mean i think lloyd george's achievements in in laying the foundations for welfare state in as a leader who guides Britain through the First World War. I mean, I think those are immense achievements, but there's quite a lot to go against that. And you can see that that might drag him down. He's just a bad man. Whereas no one would say that Attlee was a bad man. So Attlee went through to the semifinals. So we had Pitt the Younger went through.
64 因为劳合·乔治，我认为，尽管——我的意思是，我认为劳合·乔治在为福利国家奠定基础方面的成就，以及作为引导英国度过第一次世界大战的领导人，我的意思是，我认为这些是巨大的成就，但也有很多反对他的声音。你可以看出这可能会拖累他。他只是个坏人。而没有人会说艾德礼是个坏人。所以艾德礼进入了半决赛。所以我们有小皮特进入了。
We had Attlee go through. We had Gladstone go through. And then the last quarterfinal was Asquith, who we've talked about in the previous episode, against Winston Churchill, the number one seed. And really, Churchill is the last person that we've got to talk here. He's, unsurprisingly, he plays a key figure in the drama of this sporting occasion yeah he wins against askwith but interestingly not by as much as you
我们有艾德礼进入了。我们有格莱斯顿进入了。然后最后一场四分之一决赛是阿斯奎斯，我们在上一集讨论过他，对阵头号种子温斯顿·丘吉尔。真的，丘吉尔是我们在这里必须讨论的最后一个人。不出所料，他在这次体育盛事的戏剧性中扮演了关键角色，是的，他赢了阿斯奎斯，但有趣的是，并没有你想象的那么多
might suspect because he wins 58 yeah and that was a sign of what was coming the next round right because i mean at that point when i saw that churchill had only just beaten askwith i sort of thought then well churchill is going to find it very, very hard to go through to the final once he's into the semis. So he was drawn. Yes, so he's drawn against Gladstone. So Attlee is against Pitt. And I think unsurprisingly, no one will be surprised,
因为他以58%获胜，是的，那是下一轮即将发生什么的信号，对吧？因为我的意思是，在那一点上，当我看到丘吉尔只是勉强击败了阿斯奎斯时，我当时就想，好吧，丘吉尔一旦进入半决赛，想要进入决赛将会非常非常困难。所以他被抽到了。是的，所以他被抽到了对阵格莱斯顿。所以艾德礼对阵皮特。我想不出所料，没有人会感到惊讶，
he beats Pitt by 65%. So Attlee goes into the final. Gladstone against Churchill was another Titanic battle. The grand old man, you know, what a run he's had these classic sporting encounters. And it was always going to be huge against Churchill. And ultimately,
他以65%的得票率击败了皮特。所以艾德礼进入了决赛。格莱斯顿对阵丘吉尔是另一场泰坦尼克号式的战斗。那位伟大的老者，你知道，他经历了一场多么精彩的比赛，这些经典的体育对决。而且对阵丘吉尔的比赛注定会非常盛大。最终，
as he'd done in the match against Israeli, he comes through as the shadows are lengthening over the stadium and he ends up winning 55%. So Churchill is knocked out. So both the two. Exactly the same pattern. Both the two great war leaders, Pitt the Younger and Churchill, are knocked out. The two great reformers, Attlee and Gladstone, go through. So let's talk about Churchill because Churchill, obviously, even when he's not making it to the final, is what everyone's talking about.
就像他在对阵迪斯雷利的比赛中所做的那样，当阴影拉长在体育场上时，他以55%的得票率获胜。所以丘吉尔被淘汰了。所以两位伟大的战时领导人，小皮特和丘吉尔，都以完全相同的模式被淘汰了。两位伟大的改革者，艾德礼和格莱斯顿，晋级了。所以让我们谈谈丘吉尔，因为丘吉尔，显然，即使他没有进入决赛，也是每个人都在谈论的话题。
Yes. He's Brazil, isn't he? He's the Brazil in this analogy. Now, I think the thing with Churchill is that Churchill is in a different league from everybody else in the entire tournament. And actually, when we advertised the tournament, the historian Alan Allport, who's written, started this fantastic project writing sort of social histories of the Second World War. He put a message on Twitter and said,
是的。他是巴西队，不是吗？在这个类比中，他是巴西队。现在，我认为丘吉尔的问题在于，丘吉尔在整个锦标赛中处于与其他人不同的水平。实际上，当我们宣传这次锦标赛时，历史学家艾伦·奥尔波特，他写过，开始了这项伟大的工程，撰写二战的社会史。他在推特上发了一条消息说，
you know, if there's a rotund fellow in the draw with a bow tie, there's no point running the tournament because everybody knows that Churchill will win. Because, of course, Churchill wins every poll done normally to decide the greatest Briton. When the BBC did their huge landmark Great Britain's poll in 2002, I think Churchill won it pretty comfortably. He's on the money.
你知道，如果抽签里有一个系着领结的圆滚滚的家伙，那举办这个锦标赛就没意义了，因为每个人都知道丘吉尔会赢。因为当然，丘吉尔赢得了通常决定最伟大英国人的每一次民意调查。当BBC在2002年进行他们那次巨大的地标性“最伟大的英国人”民调时，我想丘吉尔赢得很轻松。他就是那个标杆。
Was it John Lennon at nine? John Lennon was ahead of all sorts of people who should have been. But mind you, Princess Diana was very high. Yes, they were. But it was, yeah, Churchill was number one, and very clearly. It was obvious that Churchill was going to win. And, you know, Churchill is one of the few children know Churchill's name people have no interest in history whatsoever know of Churchill and Churchill is seen abroad as a symbol of Britishness but of
约翰·列侬排在第九吗？约翰·列侬排在了很多本不该排在他前面的人前面。但话说回来，戴安娜王妃的排名也非常高。是的，他们确实很高。但确实，是的，丘吉尔是第一名，而且非常明显。很明显丘吉尔会赢。而且，你知道，丘吉尔是少数几个孩子们都知道名字的人之一，那些对历史毫无兴趣的人也知道丘吉尔，而且丘吉尔在国外被视为英国性的象征，但
course okay so on that on that Dominic on that yeah could I could I just read a couple of tweets yeah actually I'm just going to read one tweet here. This is on the Gladstone Churchill. It's from Kappel Loft, who's a big Churchill fan. He says, seriously, the voters in this competition are nuts. Gladstone repealed the soap tax, introduced competitive civil service exams, and destroyed his party over home rule. Churchill played the leading role in saving Britain from Nazi domination. No contest in a sane world. Yes.
当然，好吧，关于这一点，多米尼克，关于这一点，我能读几条推文吗？是的，实际上我只想读一条推文。这是关于格莱斯顿对阵丘吉尔的。来自卡佩尔·洛夫特，他是一个丘吉尔的铁杆粉丝。他说，说真的，这次比赛的选民都疯了。格莱斯顿废除了肥皂税，引入了竞争性的公务员考试，并因爱尔兰自治问题摧毁了自己的政党。丘吉尔在拯救英国免受纳粹统治方面发挥了主导作用。在一个理智的世界里，这根本没法比。是的。
He got that a lot. It's got a point of view isn't it yeah um and i think this is the funny thing with churchill now churchill has this single signal achievement that is that for a lot of people transcends all else not least because it's the foundational moment of modern british identity you know it's our moment of sainthood it's we stood alone against the Nazis and saved the world, which is kind of drummed into every freeborn Britain. But is it anymore?
他经常收到这样的评论。这确实是一个观点，不是吗？嗯，我认为这就是丘吉尔现在有趣的地方，丘吉尔有这个单一的标志性成就，对于很多人来说，这超越了一切，尤其是因为这是现代英国身份的奠基时刻，你知道，这是我们神圣的时刻，是我们独自对抗纳粹并拯救世界的时刻，这被灌输给每一个自由出生的英国人。但现在还是这样吗？
I mean, because that's what's so interesting about this result is that it does suggest, I mean, I know that people on Twitter almost invariably are to the left of the political centre of gravity beyond Twitter. But it is interesting that he seems to have become an absolute lightning rod in the ongoing culture war. And whenever there's some protest, people end up trying to,
我的意思是，因为这个结果最有趣的地方在于它确实表明，我的意思是，我知道推特上的人几乎总是处于政治重心偏左的位置，超出了推特本身。但有趣的是，他似乎已经成为了正在进行的文化战争中的绝对避雷针。每当有抗议活动时，人们最终都会试图，
you know, the police end up defending the statue, whether they need to or not. So even, you know, the, you mentioned the, the,
你知道，警察最终会去保护雕像，不管他们需不需要。所以即使是，你提到了，
the, the protests, the, the way that the police handled the commemoration of Sarah Everard in Clapham Common. Somehow that ended up with police standing in a ring around Churchill's statue. And there's something clearly, it's almost, I guess, divorced from Churchill as a historical figure. And he's become a myth. You know, the idea that Churchill basically saved the world, that's one myth. I mean, he clearly plays an absolutely key decisive role, but I don't think he doesn't win the war single-handedly.
那些抗议，警察处理萨拉·埃弗拉德在克拉珀姆公地纪念活动的方式。不知何故，最终导致警察站在丘吉尔雕像周围围成一圈。这显然有些东西，我猜，已经与作为历史人物的丘吉尔脱节了。他已经变成了一个神话。你知道，丘吉尔基本上拯救了世界的想法，那是一个神话。我的意思是，他显然扮演了一个绝对关键的决定性角色，但我不认为他不是单枪匹马赢得了战争。
And then on the other side, the idea that he sends tanks in to mow down innocent miners and protesters, and that he's responsible for the Bengal famine, which is the other much-spoken-about charge against him. Now, I'm no expert on this, but my brother is, and knows everything about shipping lanes and shipping requirements in the Second World War. It assures me that Churchill was not responsible for the Bengal famine. Well, he's clearly not responsible for it. I mean, it's obviously a ludicrous claim. I mean, you're not responsible for a famine famine. Well, he's clearly not responsible for it. I mean, yeah, I mean, it's obviously a ludicrous claim.
而在另一边，他派坦克去碾压无辜的矿工和抗议者，以及他应对孟加拉饥荒负责，这是对他另一个被广泛讨论的指控。现在，我不是这方面的专家，但我哥哥是，他了解二战中关于航道和航运需求的一切。他向我保证，丘吉尔不对孟加拉饥荒负责。好吧，他显然不对它负责。我的意思是，这显然是一个荒谬的说法。我的意思是，你不对一场饥荒负责。好吧，他显然不对它负责。我的意思是，是的，我的意思是，这显然是一个荒谬的说法。
I mean, you're not responsible for a famine that's taking place. You might be criticised for your handling of it. But I mean, to be fair to Churchill... I think in certain ways, I mean, really, Churchill killed three million people or whatever. Yeah, you read that all the time now, Tom. And that seems at least as big a myth. So on both sides, what people are arguing about are essentially untrue myths that nevertheless are rooted clearly in what makes Churchill such a fascinating character,
我的意思是，你不对一场正在发生的饥荒负责。你可能会因为处理方式而受到批评。但我的意思是，公平地说，丘吉尔……我认为在某些方面，我的意思是，真的，丘吉尔杀了三百万人什么的。是的，你现在到处都能读到这个，汤姆。这看起来至少是一个同样大的神话。所以双方争论的本质上都是不真实的神话，但这些神话显然植根于使丘吉尔成为如此迷人角色的原因，
that he is the guy who, more than any other political figure, ensures that Britain fights on against the Nazis and is able to fight on against the Nazis. He is also very much a figure who believes in the British Empire and definitely has a kind of racist sense of the superiority of, I guess, Europeans, but specifically the British. Yeah. And both of those are incredibly resonant in the world of 2021. Well, see, this is the point where my sort of jolly facade crumbles and my true identity as an author of intemperate tirades will emerge. Right, okay, so give us an intemperate tirade. Well, I think – well, actually, if I can sort of reassemble my facade,
他是那个比任何其他政治人物都更能确保英国继续对抗纳粹并能够继续对抗纳粹的人。他也是一个非常相信大英帝国的人，并且绝对有一种关于欧洲人，特别是英国人优越性的种族主义观念。是的。这两者在2021年的世界中都产生了难以置信的共鸣。好吧，看，这就是我那种快乐的外表崩溃，我作为不温不火的抨击文章作者的真实身份显露出来的地方。好吧，好的，那给我们来一段不温不火的抨击吧。好吧，我想——好吧，实际上，如果我能重新组装我的外表，
I think Churchill has become shorthand for Britain and Britishness and for British history, actually. So the attack on a Churchill statue is not an attack so much on Churchill himself, but it's an attack. It's an almost kind of Oedipal attack on Britain and Britain's sense of itself and its sense of its own. It's an attack on Gammons, isn't it? I mean, basically, I don't think that protesters really care about Churchill, but they know that attacking him annoys people that they want to annoy.
我认为丘吉尔已经成为了英国和英国性，实际上也是英国历史的代名词。所以对丘吉尔雕像的攻击与其说是对丘吉尔本人的攻击，不如说是一种攻击。这几乎是一种对英国和英国自我意识及其自身意识的俄狄浦斯式的攻击。这是对“甘蒙人”（Gammons，指保守的英国白人男性）的攻击，不是吗？我的意思是，基本上，我不认为抗议者真的关心丘吉尔，但他们知道攻击他会惹恼他们想要惹恼的人。
People like me. Middle England, the voice of Middle England. Yes, exactly. Yeah, but also people abroad. Because you said this, you know, what's been interesting about this is the perspective of people outside Britain. So Churchill beats As um askwith goes into the semi-final he he he loses to gladstone yeah so it's it's a gladstone um atley final and we had this um the tweet from david zirek from um israel Israel, who says this about Atlee.
像我这样的人。英格兰中部，英格兰中部的声音。是的，完全正确。是的，但也包括国外的人。因为你说了这个，你知道，这次比赛有趣的地方在于英国以外的人的视角。所以丘吉尔击败了阿斯奎斯，阿斯奎斯进入了半决赛，他输给了格莱斯顿，是的，所以这是一场格莱斯顿对阵艾德礼的决赛，我们有来自以色列的大卫·齐雷克的推文，他是这样评价艾德礼的。
He may have been great domestically, but he and especially Bevin are badly remembered here in Israel for refusing to remove limits on Jewish immigration after the war. By the way, to you in the UK, history is a spectator sport. To us in Israel, it is participatory. But that's kind of interesting. So that's the perspective there is that Attlee is not actually good either. Well, okay. Restrictions on Jewish immigration. How many people died in partition, Tom? Yeah, so partition and, yeah.
他在国内可能很伟大，但他，尤其是贝文，在以色列这里因为拒绝在战后取消犹太移民限制而名声很差。顺便说一句，对你们英国人来说，历史是一项观赏性运动。对我们以色列人来说，它是参与性的。但这很有趣。所以那里的观点是艾德礼实际上也不好。好吧，好的。对犹太移民的限制。汤姆，有多少人在分治中死亡？是的，所以分治和，是的。
But he then goes on to say, and I tweeted back to him and said, well, who do you want to win? And David Zerich says, Churchill, exclamation mark. I'm shocked that he didn't. And then he says says rather touchingly, by the way, I am the link between Churchill and Kennedy. When I met Ben Gurion in Montreal in 1961, see my pic. And there's a picture of a little boy with Ben Gurion.
但他接着说，我回复他说，好吧，你希望谁赢？大卫·齐雷克说，丘吉尔，感叹号。我很震惊他没有赢。然后他说，说得相当感人，顺便说一句，我是丘吉尔和肯尼迪之间的联系人。当我在1961年在蒙特利尔见到本-古里安时，看我的照片。照片里是一个小男孩和本-古里安。
It was between his visit to his old friend Winston and his then secret meeting in New York with JFK. So that's kind of wonderful. It's a wonderful thing to have, isn't it? And I think actually what that captures, Tom, I agree with you. I mean, to people abroad, unless they're incredibly politicised,
那是在他访问他的老朋友温斯顿和他在纽约与肯尼迪的秘密会面之间。所以这很美妙。这是一种美妙的事情，不是吗？而且我认为实际上这捕捉到了这一点，汤姆，我同意你的看法。我的意思是，对于国外的人来说，除非他们非常有政治倾向，
it probably does seem demented not to pick Churchill. Because abroad, Churchill is a symbol of Britishness. And he's one of those few characters who has imprinted himself on the imagination of the planet. So to not choose him, I think you can tell from the responses we got on Twitter, to overseas fans of this podcast seem like a demented
不选丘吉尔看起来确实很疯狂。因为在国外，丘吉尔是英国性的象征。他是少数几个在地球的想象力中留下印记的人物之一。所以不选择他，我想你可以从我们在推特上得到的回复中看出，对于这个播客的海外粉丝来说，这看起来像是一种疯狂的
act of national self-harm and self-punishment. National self-harm. I hope I'm not understating that, am I Tom? You've heard it here. People say that sport isn't isn't important but but clearly the result in this dominic has casted as an act of national
国家自我伤害和自我惩罚的行为。国家自我伤害。我希望我没有低估这一点，对吧，汤姆？你在这里听到了。人们说体育不重要，但显然多米尼克，这次的结果被视为一种国家
self-harm um no no i think that's entirely reasonable dominic and i can see why the daily mail employ you but actually no it's in a way it was fun that Churchill didn't make it. Had he won, it would have been predictable, wouldn't it? It would be very boring. Whereas it was actually great to have, I think particularly to have Gladstone running. We've got a lot of people talking about Victorian arguing about civil service examinations and soap taxes. And that's great to see, isn't it?
自我伤害，嗯，不，不，我认为这完全合理，多米尼克，我能看出为什么《每日邮报》雇佣你，但实际上不，在某种程度上，丘吉尔没能进入决赛很有趣。如果他赢了，那将是可预测的，不是吗？那会非常无聊。而实际上能有格莱斯顿参赛真是太棒了。我们有很多关于维多利亚时代的人在争论公务员考试和肥皂税。这很好，不是吗？
The fans, you know, they can't go to the pub and argue about it, but they can do it online. Wonderful, wonderful to see i suppose the disappointment for me was that the final was a bit for non-event because you knew that as soon as atlee got to the i think atlee churchill final would have got generated greater discussion because probably more churchill aficionados would have piled in whereas as it was poor old gladstone because his party the liberal party or the liberal Democrats as it now is it's basically become in electoral terms a little bit of an irrelevance he doesn't he didn't really have a constituency batting for him whereas Attlee clearly if you were at all left-leaning Attlee was your man from the start of the tournament to the end I mean I have to say I
粉丝们，你知道，他们不能去酒吧争论这个，但他们可以在网上做。太棒了，太棒了，我看到我猜对我来说失望的是决赛有点虎头蛇尾，因为你知道一旦艾德礼进入了，我想艾德礼对阵丘吉尔的决赛会产生更大的讨论，因为可能有更多的丘吉尔爱好者会涌入，而事实是，可怜的老格莱斯顿，因为他的政党，自由党或现在的自由民主党，在选举方面基本上已经变得无关紧要了，他并没有真正拥有一个支持他的选区，而艾德礼显然，如果你有任何左倾倾向，艾德礼从锦标赛开始到结束都是你的人选，我的意思是，我必须说我
I'm very happy to see both of them win. I think they're both kind of admirable, heroic figures who achieved amazing things. But purely from the sporting sense, the grand old man had had such an amazing run. I did want to see him go all the way. Who was the romantic favourite by the end, wasn't he? The romantic favourite. I think the favourite of the sports fan, perhaps, rather than the politics fan. But anyway, I thought it was a great tournament.
我很高兴看到他们两个都赢了。我认为他们都是令人钦佩的、英雄般的人物，取得了惊人的成就。但纯粹从体育意义上讲，这位伟大的老者经历了一段如此惊人的旅程。我确实想看到他一路走到底。他到最后是浪漫的最爱，不是吗？浪漫的最爱。我认为他可能是体育迷的最爱，而不是政治迷的最爱。但无论如何，我认为这是一场伟大的锦标赛。
Really, really enjoyable. As I say, I did genuinely in some matches find myself checking the score at regular intervals. And I think that we should do something like this again, don't you? I do. Now, we've had various discussions about future World Cups. So,
真的，真的非常愉快。正如我所说，我确实在一些比赛中发现自己会定期查看比分。而且我认为我们应该再做一次这样的事情，你不觉得吗？我也这么认为。现在，我们已经就未来的世界杯进行了各种讨论。所以，
Jonathan Wilson did the great sports writer, did the draw for us and did the punditry. And there was talk of a World Cup of Wilsons. That would be good, wouldn't it? Wilson Pickett against Harold Wilson. He could be both pundit and participant. But I think maybe there's talk of a World Cup of Gods. Now, I think that would be a fun World Cup.
乔纳森·威尔逊，伟大的体育作家，为我们进行了抽签并担任了评论员。有人谈论威尔逊世界杯。那会很棒，不是吗？威尔逊·皮克特对阵哈罗德·威尔逊。他既可以是评论员也可以是参赛者。但我认为也许有人在谈论众神世界杯。现在，我认为那会是一场有趣的世界杯。
What do you think about a World Cup of Gods? Well, who wouldn't like to see Athena against Odin in the quarterfinal? Yeah, it'd be a thriller. Think about Lockheed Thor. Yeah. Let's do that. So let's aim to do that in, what, a couple of months or something. Exactly.
你觉得众神世界杯怎么样？好吧，谁不想看到雅典娜在四分之一决赛中对阵奥丁呢？是的，那会是一场惊悚片。想想洛基对阵索尔。是的。让我们这样做吧。所以让我们争取在，什么，几个月后或者什么的做这件事。完全正确。
So keep listening to the podcast, and then we'll surprise you with the World Cup of Ancient Gods. I think we should disallow gods who are currently worshipped i think that would be sensible it would be an unwise and unwise venture um yes i think i think that would be a very sort of defunct gods yeah okay well it's all been very exciting thank you for listening i hope you enjoyed it we will be back uh in a couple of days now, won't it? Um, what have we got coming up,
所以继续收听播客，然后我们会用古代众神世界杯给你们一个惊喜。我认为我们应该禁止目前仍被崇拜的神，我认为那会是明智的，那将是一次不明智的冒险，嗯，是的，我认为那会是非常，某种已废弃的神，是的，好的，好吧，这一切都非常令人兴奋，谢谢你们的收听，希望你们喜欢，我们会在几天后回来，不是吗？嗯，我们接下来有什么，
Dominic? Remind me. Uh, we've got, um, uh, we've got, we've got Ben McIntyre,
多米尼克？提醒我一下。嗯，我们有，嗯，我们有，我们有本·麦金泰尔，
of course. We've got Ben McIntyre on spies. We've got Ben McIntyre talking about spies. Yes. So, so lots of excitement there. Um, and in a couple of months,
当然。我们有本·麦金泰尔谈论间谍。我们有本·麦金泰尔谈论间谍。是的。所以，所以那里有很多令人兴奋的事情。嗯，几个月后，
perhaps we'll be back with the World Cup of Ancient Gods. Thank you very much for listening. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
也许我们会带着古代众神世界杯回来。非常感谢你们的收听。再见。感谢收听《历史的余味》。如需额外剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。那是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。